voici les derniers clichés d'eph guni
Prigogine depuis plus d'une semaine le
chef de la ministre Wagner n'a pas fait
de réapparition publique suite à sa
révolte avortée il se trouverait en
Biélorussie aux côtés de son ami de 20
ans le président le cashingo rien à
filtrer sur l'accord passé entre Moscou
et Minsk pour exciterait Prigogine sur
la chaîne telegram le groupe Wagner
aurait indiqué cessé tout recrutement et
activités en Ukraine pour un mois mais
d'après plusieurs médias dont la BBC il
y aurait encore une douzaine de centres
de recrutement actifs qui pourraient
déployer des unités en 24 heures sur le
front sur ces images satellites ce camp
militaire situé à une heure de mince qui
était quasi désert le 15 juin deux
semaines plus tard la photo prise au
même endroit montre bien plus
d'activités
deux analyses pourraient expliquer ce
changement d'un côté Alexandre
lucaschenko verrait d'un bon œil ces
mercenaires entraîner les militaires
biélorus de l'autre les hommes de Wagner
refuseraient en grande majorité
d'intégrer l'armée russe régulière pour
des questions principalement
idéologiques vu de Moscou féministe sont
perçus par les médias russes comme un
groupe cupide intéressé par l'argent
plus que par la défense de la Russie le
siège à Saint-Pétersbourg a été
perquisitionné et les enseignes du
groupe progressivement effacées mais un
démantèlement total reste compliqué en
raison de la structure tentaculaire du
groupe une entreprise pourtant financée
et voulu par Vladimir Poutine
et à